cheese lovers guys let's talk about
booze I love my cocktails but what I
don't love is the double whammy sugar
and booze hangover that you get from
super boozy sugary drinks oh it's not
good so that's why I developed a little
technique that I call balanced boozing
that basically involves going easy on
the liquor in my cocktails avoiding the
super sugary drinks and having a few
sips of water between each sip of
alcohol so today I'm going to share with
you three of my favorite fall cocktails
to help you get through those holidays
even with crazy Uncle Bill let's get
started first up is my own my pumpkin
chai cocktail first I bring some water
to a boil in a small saucepan and add in
some diced pear maple syrup pumpkin
puree ginger pumpkin pie spice and lemon
juice cover and simmer for about five
minutes
then turn off the heat add in the chai
tea bag and vanilla and let it sit until
fully cooled using a slotted spoon
remove all of the pear ginger and tea
bits and then set that aside then to
make the cocktail I add one else at the
Bourbon and one and a half ounces of the
pumpkin syrup to a mixer with some ice
shake until well chilled then strain
into a cup top with a little bit of club
soda and garnish with a piece of candy
ginger next is my apple pie mimosa I
start by lightly wetting the rim of a
champagne flute and dipping it into some
ground cinnamon then I put two ounces of
apple cider into each champagne flute
and top it off with three ounces of
sparkling wine garnish with a slice of
apple and enjoy finally my apple and
cranberry kombucha sangria in a large
pitcher I mix together one ball of white
wine two cups of ginger kombucha sliced
Apple sliced lemon and some
frozen cranberries pug eyes it's 5 p.m.
somewhere and I am ready to drink up
seriously these are my favorite videos
to shoot like like we need to write more
of these kinds of videos like every
single week so just just put that in the
calendar ok I hope you enjoyed my fall
cocktail video if you did give me the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
what you're gonna be drinking this
holiday season and maybe I'll lighten it
up for you subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen